the Joe Rogan experience yeah I've had
all a bunch of stem-cell shot into my
shoulder that healed it up but I had
some pretty significant shoulder
injuries yeah you did you did the labrum
surgery rotator cuff another surgery I
put on a full length rotator cuff tear
okay and they used exosomes and it was
gone the next MRI have the the tear was
gone yeah just it goes it just seals up
they did exosomes with platelet-rich
plasma and they mix it together and
shoot it into the injury and I went
through the rehab and then I got another
mr MRI like six months later eight
months later whatever it was when it
started feeling good they said well
let's take a look at it and they were
like holy [ __ ] like dr. Rodney McGee
from Vegas who did a lot of UFC stuff he
goes do you know how crazy that is
he's like your tear is gone doesn't
exist anymore
that's I gotta see that it's like
[ __ ] next-level [ __ ] why don't they
offer that to us when we have [ __ ] up
injuries I'm like my neck my back like I
mean that how are you well I mean if
they really think that you need it and
date my I don't know if they know that
you have this injury like maybe you have
to ask for it I but I feel like if you
you're one of your top guys you would
want us to be back healthy [ __ ] best as
we can possibly be so it's not
prohibitively expensive for the UFC
either if you talk to dr. Davidson or
talk to DOM you know connect you with
dr. McGee ya know they were two went out
to chose with McGee yeah he's got the
good [ __ ] he's a doctor rowdy McGee in
Vegas is always at the cutting edge he's
that guys like every time I talk to him
there's some new thing that's going on
there's new stuff now called Wharton's
jelly that is even more powerful than
any of the previous tim cell ones and i
had that [ __ ] shot into my shoulder too
and that's all in the states all in the
states
yeah cuz stuff in the state's now is way
more potent than it was just five years
ago okay exactly more you had a guest on
and they were talking about going to
Neil Riordan yeah animal Panama I sent
my mom down there yeah my mom has a
pretty bad knee and it sent it down and
it helped it but she's gonna go down
again it's a it's a heavy [ __ ] man they
can they do IV stem cells - they do a
gang [ __ ] down there yeah so so let me
ask you so what exactly does it help
does it help with like regenerate soft
tissue
so like would that be like a tendon
ligament tendons ligaments muscle
injuries things along those lines they
can regenerate ligaments regenerate
tissue tears you know like stuff where
you ordinarily would have to get things
sewn up but here's a perfect example my
friend John his wife had a labrum tear
so she had a tear in the labrum of her
hip yeah and the doctors saying like
most likely we're gonna have to fix this
it's gonna be a big deal it's gonna be
like yeah off your feet like you have to
you can't put any weight on it for I
think like six to eight weeks or
something like that well she got
exosomes shot in there and then when
they went in for the second MRI there's
nothing no injury to God it's freaky
freaky so she had a little bit of a
deformity in the bone of her hip that
was causing an irritation against the
labrum they sanded down that part of the
hip that was kind of bothering her they
they like cut away the part of the bone
that's intruding on the labrum so yeah
it clears the path so it was not that
invasive a surgery and in six weeks
later she's good to go I mean she's
rehabbing and everything and she's still
like they still have to cut her open a
little bit yeah but the big one was the
labrum tear and all that was fixed
[Applause]